you're a researcher working at site 19
for the scp foundation just going about
your day minding your own business
you've spent your morning keeping an eye
on the d-classes who are keeping their
eyes on
scp-173 the clock strikes noon and you
decide to break for lunch where you'll
enjoy the delicious tuna sandwich you
made for yourself this morning you're
sitting alone in one of site 19's
numerous employee break rooms chewing
the first bite of your sandwich as you
try in vain to wrap your head around
scp-055 the unknowable anti-meme when a
scent wafts past your nose it's the
worst thing you've ever smelled like a
mix of body odor dirt and musty old
clothes you turn to look for the source
of the smell and suddenly realize that
you're not alone in the room there's a
man standing next to you he's tall with
a scruffy face lined by age he's wearing
a long woolen coat that dangles past his
knees he doesn't say a word though he's
just staring but not at you act your
sandwich before you can open your tuna
filled mouth to say something his grade
code opens and a long green tentacle
slithers out grabbing your sandwich and
pulling it out of your hands you start
to protest and then another limb emerges
from the coat long and reptilian it
places a single finger upon your lips
and shushes you the tentacle lifts your
delicious tuna sandwich up to the
strange man's face and he starts to eat
it in front of you maintaining eye
contact the entire time
then after he finishes your lunch he
just turns and makes his exit leaving
you alone in the break room and hungry
later that day you request a meeting
with your supervisor hoping to get some
answers about what you saw in the break
room maybe some compensation for the
stolen sandwich or at the very least a
little sympathy for how hungry you've
been all afternoon but your supervisor
does none of that instead the color
drains from their cheeks and they begin
to sweat you ask what's wrong and your
supervisor murmurs one brief sentence
you just met the most powerful person in
the world of course you've heard of the
o5 council they're the most powerful
people in the entire scp foundation both
in terms of institutional control and
perhaps even literal raw power depending
on who you ask they might be a group of
elite foundation agents and researchers
who rose to the very top of the pyramid
a secret room full of dusty old
power-hungry bureaucrats or a cabal of
super-powered beings that transcend the
bounds of our dimension in short almost
nobody is more powerful than the
foundation's o5 council but who oversees
the overseers if anyone at all if they
do exist then who's the one figure in
foundation lore more secret than the
most secretive group imaginable there's
only one answer to this question a
figure known only as
the administrator if you spend some time
researching the affairs of the scp
foundation there's no doubt you would
have heard the name perhaps in a heavily
redacted file or whispered in fear by a
site director worrying about incurring
the mysterious figure's wrath today we
intend to do the impossible and we just
might end up terminated by the red right
hand because of it but we're going to
gather all the information available to
us and try to figure out who or what the
clandestine administrator actually is
we'll answer your most obvious question
first what's with those weird sandwich
stealing arms one of the few almost
universally accepted facts about the
administrator is their possession of
scp-260
also known as the code of many arms
little to nothing is known about the
coat's history before it came into the
administrator's possession and given the
huge amount of power the administrator
wields within the foundation nobody has
the authority to press them for further
information the coat's interior is a
spatial anomaly from which a huge number
of anomalous limbs can emerge and
perform tasks on the wearer's behalf
it's such a useful item that the
foundation has even considered
weaponizing it for field agents as the
arms emerging from the coat are able to
perform tasks as diverse as playing the
piano with two or more hands to blocking
attacks directed towards the wearer that
otherwise would have been fatal the
limbs themselves are also varied from
normal looking human limbs to tentacles
and paws the administrator only finally
surrendered the coat to the foundation
in the end because it was taking up too
much space in their closet and
presumably needed the room for the next
season's most fashionable anomalous
clothing for centuries though you
wouldn't see the administrator without
the many armed coat that's right
centuries another almost universally
accepted fact about the administrator is
that they have a truly freakish
longevity potentially living for
hundreds of years there has likely been
more than one administrator during the
foundation's extremely long history but
each one has survived longer than any
average human it's also a widely
believed theory that the administrator
may have been a key player in the
foundation's initial creation too
there's been a number of potential names
speculated for the administrator
including frederick williams agnes
peterson kismet and the sinister alias
the spider some believe the
administrator to be fundamentally human
despite certain anomalous qualities
while others speculate that they're the
furthest thing from human this
interpretation maintains that the
administrator is an entity from a
different dimension known as the plane
where eyes can't follow and has a
freakish body made from a twisted
charcoal-like material tangled with wire
mesh and a chaos of different limbs all
hidden under scp-262
but hey the administrator species isn't
nearly as interesting as their potential
role within the foundation an issue
surrounded with nearly as much confusion
and controversy as
well everything else about them and just
like everything else with the scp
foundation the line they feed the public
is often different to the words
circulating within the foundation's
higher clearance levels if you want to
believe the official stories then the
administrator is the liaison between the
foundation and the numerous world
governments that need to cooperate with
them to ensure the successful capture of
anomalies the administrator is only
allowed to edit scp files not actually
write them due to apparent conflicts of
interest in many ways the administrator
is presented as your typical sleazy
washington insider schmoozing with
politicians and government figures to
make sure they remain sympathetic to the
foundation's cause according to
observations from people outside the
foundation who've worked with the
mysterious figure they have a pension
for finely tailored suits expensive aged
liqueurs and the amorous company of
women despite being a bit of a drunken
horndog though people tend to describe
the administrator as likable and easy to
get along with regardless of where you
fall on the political spectrum they're
also respected by many and whenever
something upsets them even powerful
world leaders are eager to try and
appease them maybe because they are
described as being freakishly strong
when the situation demands it hey even
world leaders can change their minds
when they have their arms twisted
literally while there's nothing too
outwardly bizarre about this iteration
of the administrator we don't actually
know how much of this is true a fact
that really shouldn't surprise you by
now and if being well versed in the
world of scps has taught you anything
it's that the scp foundation's pr and
disinformation teams are not to be
trusted so who can be trusted is there
any perspective on this mysterious
figure that can be taken reliably the
short answer is
no not really but we do have the next
best thing recollections from some of
the foundation's most trusted
researchers and personnel and even some
of the strange historical figures that
have heard about or even run into the
administrator what follows are some of
their answers to the question who is the
administrator professor kane pathos crow
said oh he's just something people talk
about over lunch or when they're in
between assignments it kills time and
it's a fun game to speculate on who
really calls the shots in this crazy
world field agent fritz willey said i
like to tell people he's my brother
foundation researcher dr snorlassen said
i'd like to poke at him and see what
happens just to see if any of the rumors
about being made entirely of legs and
toes are true or something like that at
least director neil ghost said no big
deal son the ever stoic dr charles gears
said there are no records of anyone by
that name working for the foundation dr
iceberg said whatever the bossman says
goes i'm not on staff to care about last
decades rumors dr glass said i never met
the guy i heard he's pretty interesting
though i'd love to sit down and have a
chat with him but he's probably too busy
i've never even gotten a call back about
it the wild card dr alto clef said ew dr
chelsea elliott said i've actually done
some research on him earliest records
are about 60 years ago and beyond that
there's some vague references to a
leader most of the records though are
incomplete or just references by name
not much of substance dr frederick
hayden said please leave me alone dr
jack bright said i've heard the guy
you're talking about he's just a
legendary thing from way back in the day
when we thought there were 1205s we said
he was there to be the tiebreaker people
don't talk about it much now anymore
probably because we don't need icons
like that to keep people together dr
jacob kensington said i think he bought
me lunch once dr wright said i heard he
lives up in a big tower at overwatch and
he watches down on the o5s from the back
of a mighty scaled dragon and he flies
the skies for free
something like that you'll have to wait
until i finish the book to hear the
whole story dr kondraki said well we
can't tell you exactly what he said but
it was shortened to the point and he was
later disciplined for his use of rather
rude language in an interview later
suppressed by the scp foundation
acclaimed horror writer stephen king
said of his interaction with the
administrator one of the oddest things
to happen to me out on the road was an
autograph session in westbrook i think a
larger gentleman approached the table
with a copy of the stan said he was a
big fan now i think i might have been a
little crazy here but when i looked at
his hand holding the book it was green i
asked if he was okay and i looked up
into his eyes they were green too he
said he was fine it was pretty scary
stuff dr tilda d moo said
no no i don't even think we humor that
one anymore it's like the mid-tier
research staff telling the new people
there's a pool on the third floor nobody
really believes it but a couple people
every year try and ask just to uh check
but yes it's a more or less dead rumor
and dr jango bridge said sure i know him
he hangs out at the pool on the fifth
floor
so we return to our original question
who is the administrator do they rule
the scp foundation or serve it are they
an anomalous human or a straight-up
monster are they a liquor-loving
political schmoozer greasing the palms
of the world's government or a
mysterious demigod who founded the
foundation and guides it on its quest to
contain the anomalous and protect
normality the fact is we don't know and
thanks to foundation misinformation
campaigns we may never know but much
like the anti-meme the administrator is
defined as much by what we don't know as
what we do and according to all sources
that's exactly how they like it but what
do you think is the truth about the
administrator just who exactly is
lurking under that coat if anyone at all
let us know in the comments and then go
check out secret group that runs the
world scp-05 council explained and scp
most dangerous secret labs and
facilities for more of the scp
foundation's most closely held secrets